komm mach einfach
[Musik]
eventuell ist die tonqualität ein
bisschen gesagt ich habe mir heute
einfach mal einen anderen platz gesucht
ein bisschen was zu geben war ganz kurz
die toilette ist er komplett scheiße
mehr bad als jetzt
und weil meine eltern gerade in england
sind und ich bin hier und muss
eigentlich vom lärm und alles mögliche
tun haben
deshalb hat alles ein bisschen deswegen
habe ich auch extra seinen neuesten mit
ihrem mann ist krank
ich hoffe dass halt nicht ganz so viele
aber auch wenn es halt dann ist es der
effekt den ich auch so ein bisschen
damit rüber bringen möchte und zwar mit
hey leute tut mir leid das ist hier so
halt ich habe mir extra micro gekauft
damit es nicht mehr halt aber wenn es
halt ist das auch der effekte ich damit
erzwingen möchte
bist du lust
vor allem geht das video schon eine
minute und bisher nur darüber geredet
dass er im keller als fünf minuten nach
und dann gibt es grossartig kann auch
mal sein dass ich so etwas mache wie
longboard machen als letztes jahr
[Musik]
ich stand noch hier auf einem longboard
so richtig ein paar sekunden später
zum 1
bloggen wurden mit freude neues
longboard um dort das jetzt hör ich mir
noch mal euren schlimmsten albtraum
einfach in die kommentare
so macht das war mein schlimmster
albtraum wahr der wo ich in einer
holzfabrik war und eines scream ähnliche
personen mich verfolgt hatte
dass er so viele tiere das ist
unglaublich ich bin ich das thema
süchtig weil mit so richtig so ts gesund
und schmeckt es gibt wenig sachen die
das beides miteinander verbinden
t und ich wir waren schon immer so also
bevor ich damit jetzt richtig anfangen
ich erst mal ist dass dieser traum mich
jahrelang illegal ist es gab vollkraft
das geht ja sager von vorne los
ich habe mich auf also einen scheiß
gegeben
ja
herzlich gucken
aber es war halt echt bei mir so dass
ich dann nächtelang nicht schlafen gehen
wollte nur eingeschlafen bin weil ich
dann irgendwie vorher drei stunden schon
im bett lag und die total umgebaut das
alles ganz hatte ich halt immer so viel
angst davor dass der traum sich
wiederholt er hat sich noch keiner
wiederholt sich auf bronze
besser da nicht gesagt ich hatte den
traum insgesamt glaube ich fünfmal oder
so schon ich lag im bett eingeschlafen
und dann war ich in dem traum in einer
riesigen alle da hat sich innerhalb wie
hier alle heute also mehr kann wirklich
niemand sagen
dass ich mich irgendwie von derart
verändert habe also meine dummen
wortwitze die waren ja schon damals
überhaupt nicht lustig in der zweiten
halle und es war halt so ein holzlager
alle da waren überall so baumstämme und
arbeitet das holz und alles und das ist
auch eigentlich dass ich das jetzt alles
noch zu gut passieren lassen kann also
das ist zwar zur hälfte man flimm das in
den acht sein das war als ich neun war
dass das neue jahr nicht so krank ne
ich hatte den traum als ich neun war
dass es jetzt einfach 15 jahre her
ich war dann in diesem scheiss halle
drin und dachgärten was macht ihr da
alle es war irgendwie der dritte inter
das dritte untergeschoss irgendwie also
das war nicht nach alle die auf der
erdoberfläche stadt sondern die
immobilie darunter war ja das stimmt
alles und da war es halt auch relativ
douglas war um mitternacht
ja das hat sein drittes untergeschoss
mit einer nacht auch an sich wenn es
nicht richtig hell dass genau diese
sorten aus hier gibt es einfach nur
richtig komisches licht und ich ganz
kurz hat der typ da nicht gerade gesagt
das ist ja komplett dunkel drin war es
halt auch innerhalb von fünf sekunden
später also es war halt gemeldet
[Musik]
schon immer wenig los gewesen ich dachte
dann einfach auch fähig ich mach mich
hier was soll ich hier was soll dieser
frau also ich muss noch ganz kurz es hat
wirklich so denke ich hier nimmt dich
einfach bei einem trauma
es spielt
kommen macht
nach irgendwas in acht stunden bist du
dann wieder da und ist euch generell mal
auf was ich sagen wollte war das man
halt während eines traums auch immer
denkt dass das hat einfach die realität
ist es halt so krank erst wenn du
aufwachst denkst du dir
dafür an alle menschen wie marienkäfer
gekleidet hier was soll ich hier was
soll dieser traum also ich muss
natürlich nicht dass es die frauen sagen
wir mal das es realität ist so
man könnte meinen wir sind brüder
anguckt und so nach vorne dann hat mich
so stream gesehen der auf einmal hier so
gegenüberstand das ist fake news
das war anders
also ich lag und hat mich aufgerichtet
aber ich hab's scream erst gesehen weil
er hinten von unserem holzblock
irgendwie hervor
das ist ganz blöd dass ich mich gerade
so detailreich daran erinnern weil ich
gleich schlafen geht und er zeigt keine
regung hatte dann soll menzer hand
ich wollte diese treppe hochgehen und
noch die treppe hoch so zehn stufen oder
so sehen also eine tür tritt die klinker
die türen verschlossen
doch die treffen wieder runter der typ
gegen die drei meter vor mir oder solche
postings gerade bei der graf mit ihr
müsst euch überlegen ich war neun
neun und hat da sonst schwachsinn
geträumt alter mittlerweile mit 9
eher gute haben die mittlerweile schon
online account der typ kommt näher als
es kommt näher auf diese fahrstuhltür zu
zwei meter davor kommt immer näher ich
dazu erdgeschoss als geschmeidige gefühl
ganz vertraut und dann auf einmal diese
tür jetzt langsam zu zögern zu lange
sein werde und dies wirklich so
in scream guckt also
ich werde jetzt lachen werden aber
irgendwie dieser traum der hat mich dann
neben wochen monate geprägt das war echt
so krass ich hatte stadtführungen
deshalb
das mir neu
aber das auch so 2014 luca nader will
sich irgendwie cooler machen als sie
eigentlich ist egal es mag ja freunde
das war es für den kontrakt auch schon
wieder ich hoffe ich habe fand ich hab
einfach so ein bisschen was anderes zu
machen und ich wollen dass hingesetzt
hat so ein bisschen anders dieses video
geschnitten also nicht wirklich anders
schneidende cent immer noch das gleiche
gewesen aber ich hab's versucht euch
kurz du hast einfach gar nicht
geschnitten
wenn die auch schon mal albträume hat
mitunter so einen ähnlichen warum hat
ein ständchen auf jeden fall eine
kommentare mit das brennt ja mein
krasseste albträume zum beispiel dass
sich in so einer holz verbrannt meine
lieben freunde an der seite will ich
meine reaktion auf ein video von mir von
vor sechs jahren jetzt auch beenden ich
habe ja gerade innerhalb dieses videos
von ihr entdeckt hey doch noch alte
longboard blogs und mir die teilweise
sieben jahre alt sind
ich glaube ich brauche ich gar nicht
fragen
[Musik]